the House approved emergency funding
overnight to address the humanitarian
crisis at the border now this follows
another Homeland Security shake-up mark
Morgan acting director of Immigration
and Customs Enforcement will take over
his acting chief of Customs and Border
Protection acts month after John Sanders
resigned unexpectedly yesterday as head
of ice Morgan has pushed for nationwide
raids on undocumented migrant families
Jeff McGee spoke with him yesterday
before the shake-up Jeff is outside the
ice headquarters in Washington I know
Jeff you wish that that news would have
broken before you did this interview but
what did Morgan have to say about
conditions at the at the facilities
well good morning Gail mark Morgan
denies that there are systemic problems
inside these border detention facilities
however he did admit that migrant
children should not be held there Border
Patrol is not a place for the kids we I
think every American could agree with
that
they are overcrowded those border patrol
stations are not designed for kids
Isis taken and more than 400,000
migrants so far this year which is
overwhelmed US border facilities about
1,000 unaccompanied migrant children are
currently in CBP custody would you want
your family there I would never want my
family in it to be detained any family
you know in a facility like that just
just like I don't think anybody would
want any of their family members being a
police station so the best way to not to
be in that Detention Facility is don't
come to our country illegally Oregon
disputes aspects of a recent DHS
inspector general's report which cites
egregious violations at some detention
facilities I just don't agree that it's
egregious conditions like a systemic
problem what word would you use I would
say that there are always challenges I
welcome non-governmental organizations
to come in and do a check-and-balance
we should always try to get better
interested president truck yesterday
said that he is very concerned about
poor border facility conditions once
again claiming without evidence and it's
an improvement from his predecessor just
remember we are treating them and doing
a much
job than the Obama administration but it
was because of president Trump's zero
tolerance policy last year that
thousands of migrant children were
systematically separated from their
parents and now admit an unprecedented
surge of migrants DHS and CBP have been
without a permanent leader for more than
two months for ice it's been nearly two
and a half years yet the Trump
administration blames deplorable
detention center conditions on a lack of
money from Congress Mexico is doing much
more for us than frankly the Democrats
in Congress but as we mentioned last
night House Democrats passed a four
point five billion dollar aid package
that includes money for food water
sanitary items and services for migrants
the bill also contains though
restrictions on how that money is spent
and includes no funding for the border
wall the White House says President
Trump will veto that bill meanwhile the
Republicans in the Senate are working on
their own version of a 4.5 billion
dollars aid bill with fewer restrictions
though Tony Jeff begins for us Jeff
thank you very much